il mio intervento è incentrato sul tema
delle emozioni il flusso delle emozioni
quindi non posso non chiedermi come
state vediamo un po per alzata di mano
quanti di voi stanno bene
però devo dire che lo spettacolo ha
funzionato
quanti di voi stanno male nessuno
qualcuno lo zio ok poi vedo che c'è
sempre qualche astenuto va bene così è
se vi chiedessi cosa vuol dire stare
bene cosa vuol dire stare male oppure
così così vi pregherei di rispondere
alla mia sollecitazione quindi al come
stai
chiamando in causa una o più emozioni
inizio io come sto in questo momento beh
indubbiamente un po intimorita agitata
ma anche fortunatamente soddisfatta
entusiaste divertita quindi timore
agitazione e gioia divertimento cosa
sono se non emozioni ebbene osservando
le relazioni sia lavorative che extra
lavorative che connotano un po il mio
quotidiano mi sono resa conto che spesso
la risposta ad una domanda forse banale
come il come stai
non sia contemplata perché appunto come
stai diventata altra diventato alla
stregua di un saluto quindi neppure
ascoltiamo la risposta è mai ci teniamo
insomma in qualche modo quasi mai ci
teniamo di rispondere insomma questa
sollecitazione a chiamando in causa una
narrazione che contempli anche il nostro
vissuto emozionale
ebbene la nostra vita è emozione e
l'emozione ci dà vita che cosa si
emoziona beh il sorriso e la
spensieratezza di un bambino
il traguardo raggiunto della laurea
piuttosto che dell'altro
non lavorano oppure non so a rimanere
imbottigliati nel traffico quando magari
abbiamo poco tempo a disposizione
o ancora la perdita di una persona cara
a causa di un lutto per un licenziamento
quindi appunto tutto è emozione le
emozioni anno lo straordinario potere di
stravolgere le nostre giornate in
positivo ma anche in negativo
condizionano i nostri umori le nostre
relazioni e quindi in definitiva le
grado di soddisfazione personale nei
prossimi quindici minuti ciò che vorrei
compiere assieme a voi è un viaggio nel
mondo delle vostre nostre emozioni con
una finalità specifica cioè quella di
fare sì che voi possiate uscire da
questa sala con una consapevolezza
maggiore nel vostro mondo emotivo quindi
impariamo dapprima conoscere un po
meglio queste sconosciute a
familiarizzare con loro col fine di
capirle comprenderle e poi perché no
anche gestirle al meglio
nella mia esperienza di formatrice
psicologa ho avuto modo di accompagnare
persone che nascondevano emozioni quali
la rabbia invidia e rancore sotto il
tappeto
altri invece che rimanevano come dire
preda di una ruminazione costante su ciò
che è stato e ai noi non potrà mai più
essere cambiato
in tutte queste appunto situazioni mi
sono resa conto che le emozioni giocano
un ruolo vitale oserei dire estremamente
rilevante perché per quel che concerne
il grado di benessere piuttosto che
malessere del singolo ma anche del
sistema in cui la persona è via via
inserita lo sapete o no che non esistono
due zebre con le striature uguali fuori
di metafora ovviamente quello che vorrei
condividere con voi e che non esiste non
esistono due persone all'interno di
questa sala e ovviamente anche al di
fuori di essa che provano esprimono
percepiscono la medesima emozione con le
con la stessa intensità con le stesse
accezioni con le stesse sfaccettature
quindi quello che vi dirò che vi chiedo
di farlo vostro ovviamente però in
maniera costruttiva ossia personalizzato
del tutto alla vostra esperienza di vita
e di lavoro
eh si anche di lavoro
oggi stiamo assistendo a quella che
potrebbe essere definita come un
irresistibile irrefrenabile ascesa delle
emozioni nel campo manageriale di
organizzativo cioè ci si sta finalmente
rendendo conto che le emozioni al lavoro
incidono non solo sul grado di benessere
personale lavorativo ed organizzativo ma
anche sulla qualità delle nostre
performance
un motivo in più direi per imparare a
conoscere un po meglio no cerchiamo
quindi di definirle capire un po quale
sia la loro funzione per arrivare poi a
gestirle nella maniera più adeguata
cosa sono le emozioni le emozioni sono
delle reazioni a stimoli interni a noi
oppure esterni che causano modificazioni
a tra livelli modificazioni a livello
fisiologico a livello cognitivo e
comportamentale facciamo un esempio
sarà capitato a tutti credo di vivere la
fine di una storia d'amore o no nè di sì
qual è una delle possibili emozioni
associate a una siffatta situazione a
tristezza di rai non tristezza di non
avere più accanto a se qualcuno che sia
sia amato tanto e bene quali sono le
modificazioni che causa una tristezza a
livello fisiologico delle lacrime
iniziano iniziano a solcare il nostro
volto il respiro magari si fa un po più
affannoso a livello cognitivo iniziano
ad abitarci dei pensieri quali mi manchi
come farò ad andare avanti senza di te e
tutto ciò si ripercuote ovviamente a
livello comportamentale con azioni del
tipo magari la persona notte
chiusa in casa oppure si isola e
quant'altro cioè talvolta e tutto
potrebbe sfociare lo sappiamo e noi
anche nella depressione
a cosa servono le emozioni belle
emozioni abbiamo detto garantiscono la
nostra sopravvivenza e ci permettono di
adattarsi in maniera ci auguriamo
funzionale a quello che l'ambiente
circostante i vari ambienti e contesti
di vita che abitiamo di volta in volta
vi siete mai chiesti quante sono le
emozioni
io sì dalle ricerche dagli studi emerge
una prima grande classificazione tra le
cosiddette emozioni primarie dette anche
di base che sono universali nel senso
che si ripresentano come tali tra tutte
le popolazioni del nostro pianeta e le
cosiddette emozioni secondarie che
derivano da una combinazione di quelle
primarie e risultano essere
culturalmente apprese culturalmente
definite
a tal proposito quindi a proposito delle
emozioni secondarie un'autrice tiffany
white snake della queen mary university
di londra autrice della celebre
enciclopedia delle emozioni umane né a
classificate ben udite udite 154
sostenendo però che ce ne potrebbero
essere tante altre quindi se io vi
dicessi adesso scusate la pronuncia
lungo a ringo o non culo il primo caso
mi starei riferendo alla paura che si fa
sobbalzare
nel secondo caso hai timore che si prova
davanti a un rivale che cerca vendetta
quindi si tratta della medesima emozione
no la paura cristalli percepita
attraverso le lenti e trip in tubi una
popolazione del deserto australiano
le emozioni quindi sono funzionali sono
utili
ne va della nostra sopravvivenza però
talvolta devono essere in gergo tecnico
regolate gestite perché perché talvolta
al punto assumono delle accezioni
problematiche questo accade nel momento
in cui accedono ad esempio per intensità
oppure per durata oppure nel momento in
cui si manifestano in contesti
inadeguati non in maniera imprevedibile
ecco perché questo rappresenta un po il
cuore del mio intervento ho deciso di
proporvi un percorso di gestione di
regolazione delle vostre emozioni tratto
indubbiamente dalla letteratura
scientifica di riferimento di cui però
ho voluto proporre una sintesi
spero efficace i cinque step i cinque
verbi su cui si basa il processo di
regolazione delle emozioni che poi io
propongo durante i miei interventi di
formazione e di consulenza si basa su
questi appunto come dicevo prima 5 pazzi
primo passo prendere consapevolezza
secondo passo definire accettare il
terzo quarto integrare da ultimo
esprimere che cosa il flusso delle mie
emozioni
vediamoli nel dettaglio prendere
consapevolezza
io non prendo consapevolezza di un
emozione ogni qual volta rimango sorda
al richiamo come se io qualche modo
imbottiglia si no le emozioni e
nascondersi la bottiglia negli angoli
più bui della mia cantina
questo ovviamente insomma diventa per ma
disfunzionale questo accade ad esempio
nelle situazioni in cui l'emozione
provata non si adatta al contesto di
vita
vi faccio un esempio per farmi capire
meglio
poniamo il caso di una di una famiglia
in cui le emozioni legate alla sfera
dell'aggressività piuttosto che della
sessualità non sono contemplate che cosa
accadrà accadrà che i membri di quel
nucleo familiare faroni costretti ad
allontanare da se questi stati d'animo e
ovviamente atteggiamenti di questo tipo
potranno causare nella migliore delle
ipotesi disturbi emotivi e somatizza
nella peggiore problemi ancora più gravi
ad esempio la rabbia repressa causa che
cosa causa insonnia problemi digestivi
oppure addirittura l'infarto secondo
step di gestione delle mie emozioni
la definizione delle stesse e quindi
secondo verbo definire etichettare dare
un nome con sufficiente precisione
un'emozione da una trovata
ovviamente sono chiamata a qualche modo
arricchire il mio vocabolario emozionale
di nuovi termini quindi dovrei sapere
che la gioia si declina in entusiasmo e
divertimento
soddisfazione e felicità che la sorpresa
si declina in stupore meraviglia
ammirazione ma anche choc
si tratta di andare a vincere quella che
viene definita da molti autori come anno
alfabetizzazione emozionale di cui ai
noi spesso siamo siamo vittime
inconsapevoli ma dopotutto questa è una
provocazione naturalmente nessuno forse
ci ha mai insegnato ad emozionarci come
come si deve
ed eccoci arrivati al terzo verbo
accettare l'emozione qui forse vi
stupirò un po perché le emozioni di per
sé non sono né buona né cattiva sono
neutre la valutazione di positivo e
negativo anche etica che indubbiamente è
fortemente condizionata sia
dall'educazione che c'è stata in partita
sia dalla cultura di appartenenza
entra in gioco secondariamente cioè
entra in gioco nel momento in cui io uso
un emozione
ad esempio se in questo momento io
dovessi provare rabbia e dovessi
decidere di catapultarmi tradivo oltre
il pubblico iniziando ad imprecare a
colpire violentemente i presenti non
accadrà ok
ad ogni modo se questo dovesse accadere
sarebbe una maniera sicuramente
inadeguata e maleducata di esprimere
un'emozione quale la rabbia che ha tutto
il diritto di provare quindi
tirando le somme non è l'emozione in sé
ad essere positiva oppure negativa bensì
l'utilizzo che ne faccio ed eccoci
arrivati al quarto step integrare quarto
verbo integrare se l'inversione il
vocabolario vado a vedere che appunto
integrare significa completare qualcosa
aggiungendo gli elementi mancanti
qualcuno di voi prende degli integratori
per alzata di mano
diamo un pò ok perché lo fate per
sopperire immagino ad una carenza ad una
mancanza
cosa c'entra tutto questo con le
emozioni c'entra c'entra eccome
l'emozione non può essere scissa ma e
poi mai dalla cognizione non sono due
elementi in antitesi anzi cognizione
emozione in ragione e sentimento sono
due elementi che si completano e
integrano vicendevolmente
come fare per sposare appieno queste due
sfere significa dare voce interrogarsi
sulle emozioni che provo
ecco alcune sollecitazioni che possono
esserci utili in tal senso perché provo
proprio questo questa emozione in questo
momento perché proprio in relazione a
quella specifica persona perché proprio
in relazione a quella specifica
esperienza quindi interrogarsi sulle
mozioni per unire integrare e condizione
ed emozione
ed eccoci arrivati all'ultimo step
quindi esprimere comunicare in maniera
adeguata l'emozione da mai provata anche
qui non si tratta di comunicare le
emozioni e senza ovviamente a tenere
conto di cose del contesto piuttosto che
delle persone con cui mi relaziono
piuttosto che del momento in cui in
qualche modo insomma provo quella data
emozione quindi devo tenere conto di
analizzare osservare attorno a me una
miriade di elementi una buona regole una
regola aurea sarebbe quella di evitare
di esprimere l'emozione in maniera
eccessivamente giudicante piuttosto che
di attacco vi porto un'esemplificazione
mi è capitato recentemente di assistere
alle scene
bizzarra siamo siamo in un bar
all'ora di pranzo davanti a me è una
mamma con un figlio in piena adolescenza
che se ne sta tutto il tempo
quel col muso davanti allo smartphone
la mamma non ne può più visibile nel
senso che è irritata e arrabbiata
infastidita certo punto non ce la fa più
e in barba ai presenti strappa al figlio
il cellulare di mano lo scaraventa nella
sua borsa gli urla sei uno stupido
almeno all'ora di pranzo metti via quel
coso finirai per diventare un imbecille
ovviamente sgomento di noi presenti
imbarazzo generale e la madre che
insomma non sapeva bene se sotterrare se
stesso al figlio decidete voi
ecco una frase come sei uno stupido
finirai per diventare un imbecille e
condividerete con me probabilmente
giudicante e forse anche fuori contesto
probabilmente diverso sarebbe fatto dire
a rivolgersi al ragazzo guarda ti reputo
sufficientemente grande da capire che il
tuo atteggiamento mi infastidisce
ti prego mettevi allo smartphone almeno
per un po
funziona mi direte voi certo non con
tutti gli adolescenti
ovviamente però è certamente la via da
privilegiare
ora sono cinque i verbi che ci hanno
accompagnato in questo breve ma intenso
viaggio nel mondo delle emozioni
prendere consapevolezza definire
accettare integrare ed esprimere che
cosa nuovamente il flusso delle mie
emozioni le emozioni invadono le nostre
vite spesso senza neppure chiederci il
permesso
l'obiettivo ora cercherà chiaro spero
non è certamente quello di negarle
allontanarle da noi quanto piuttosto
quello di conoscerle un po meglio per
riuscire a gestirle in maniera
un po più efficace e mi auguro che le
indicazioni che chi vi ho fin qui
fornito possano esservi utili in tal
senso
ebbene le emozioni esercitano un potere
enorme su di noi sulle nostre vite ma
nessuno di noi ripeto nessuno di noi è
condannato a vivere in balia delle
nostre emozioni delle sue emozioni non
siamo né schiavi
nei padroni delle nostre emozioni siamo
soltanto compagni di viaggio grazie
[Applauso]